according to a new report by Millennials
have less stable working lives than
their white peers and the figures are
staggering people of color in Britain
are 58 percent more likely to be
unemployed and 47 percent more likely to
be on zero hours contracts these figures
hold even when you bring in other
factors that may have an influence like
gender family background or
qualifications meanwhile those in
unstable employment are more likely to
suffer from poor mental health which
means as Simon Woolley from operation
black vote says it's a double hit if
you're from a Bain community when we
talk about structural racism this is
exactly what it looks like it's why
British citizens from minority ethnic
backgrounds have to send on average 60%
more job applications to get a positive
response it's why some British
universities are reportedly oblivious to
the scale of racial harassment on
campuses we like to think that
discrimination automatically vanishes
that people catch tolerance by osmosis
as society moves forward and social
attitudes change but as the report on
bein millennial shows that is a
misguided assumption nothing changes
unless we all work to make it change
[Music]
yeah I agree with you on that I mean
what you said about the need to send
more applications if you're from in an
ethnic minority that is painful and I
just want to tell her a personal story
which isn't necessarily proof of racism
but it shows you the level of
competition there is out there when I
apply to university I PI to five uni's i
what i actually had already completed my
maths a-level and got an A and I was
pretty good three more a so it's because
I had four four a-levels a coming at me
and I got five rejections elected by
every single mean that's level of
competition now the surname Smith will
never give an employer pause for thought
the surname Khan Muhammad Ali wale that
might and if you let dealing with that
level of competition be slight
pause for thought is going to make a
massive difference and that's one of the
reasons where you're going to see
massive disparities in terms of the
number of applications that people need
to send out how is it to be tackled what
do you think because you've laid out
very very cogently the problems and that
is appalling of somebody with a last
name such as yours I mean that that's
unconscionable so how is it to be beat
yeah that is actually the case there was
a report a year ago I think it was that
actually sent out CVS and just changed
the name nothing else was changed and I
think you know somebody called Adam
about three or four times more likely to
get an interview there's discrimination
that but but obviously it doesn't work
you try proving it and I think it's a
really good question is something that
organizations are looking at constantly
you know racial equality think tanks etc
you can have named blind recruitment so
you erase the names from the recruitment
process okay male 22 some people are
suggesting
so Simon Woolley from operation black
vote who was involved in this latest
report has suggested that you the
government puts out a race pay ordered
so in the same way that you have one for
the gender pay gap you'd have one for
the race pay gap but it's obvious what's
clear from this latest report is that
it's obvious that it's affects people at
every stage so it's from recruitment
through whether or not you get a
promotion through to whether you know
there are people of color sitting at
board level so right the way through
it's something that you know
structurally needs to be challenged and
addressed a long time ago I proposed
that was called no bloody suntan's right
which was basically the expression and
it was based upon a long integer did
with somebody run an employment agency
saying no bloody suntan's which was one
of the phrases people used to say they
didn't want ethnic minorities when they
found him up now I think I think it's
changed
bleep does that anymore but I do think
the figures show there is still a big
issue this is a BBC famously what you
how many years ago was that 20 years ago
viewers what you did well I got
interviewed in a in a radio program and
I said that I I thought that the BBC was
hideously white and you cannot believe
the attacks I got I mean the Daily
Telegraph came in at me but you wouldn't
get today it's interesting you wouldn't
go if you said that today because
everybody recognized the problem we why
did they attack you oh just because they
said watch we're in that old the old
Daily Telegraph leader view of the world
which was a white country and all that
they wouldn't do that the world has
changed but what we try to do at the BBC
and I think companies could do is we
you've got to know the stats you've got
to know who of your employees come from
where and what their background is what
their color is that you've got to know
that and then we should put anything
said okay we're now going to question
we're now going to hold heads of
departments responsible for getting more
people from ethnic minorities into their
into their departments once you do that
miracle of miracles it happens because
their bonuses are in question there but
we and we then had a kangaroo court we
then used to get them in every three
months and saying look your numbers
haven't gotten any better what you're
gonna do about it and actually they did
get better I think it's important to get
some examples in the way my hair is now
I wouldn't want to wear this for an
interview unless I absolutely had to
because I would think that that would
pay it play a part in me not getting the
job because my hair is not European
slick straight or it's not conservative
enough family do you think that's true
she has to change her hair or do you
think that's how I'm perception there
will be an element of that I mean like I
said if you that level of prejudice just
does exist I mean I remember as a kid my
three much to my friends both of them
were white and we were sat in the
playground waiting to get let in to
lunch and there was a teacher so that
said letting people into lunch and we
thought let's just do it
a little test and so they untucked their
shirts under their Blazers and under the
pitar button pulled down their ties and
I just had one top button undone oh if
single file passed the teacher to see
which one would be get stopped it was me
yeah is that why you wear t-shirts and I
think it's a shame because I think
businesses should want to be more
diverse because when you're diverse
you're not only representing your
customers but you've got different
voices and perspectives and experiences
which i think is welcomed in business
and I think to your point anonymized
applications there can be a very good
thing I wouldn't even go as far as
saying that you're male or you're 50 I
would actually argue that your age your
gender and your name etc in many cases
no I'm just saying that actually it's
kind of irrelevant what people who say
when it comes to it you'd get older
people saying that they were
discriminated against because of their
age then you get younger people saying
that they weren't getting opportunities
because of their lack of experience I'm
running a cocktail bar right and I want
my staff on rollerskates
I want honky looking young men and a
great-looking young woman racing around
on rollerskates
I'm not going to employ me so how do I
make sure I don't interview me look I
want for my cocktail bar that's what
these kids racing around around the
dangerous that could be people submit a
picture should be able to choose the
people that show you never apply
without Sky News and coming up why there
should be nothing controversial about
protecting victims of domestic abuse
[Music]